new year new movies hopefully less crap
so welcome to Council of geeks my name
is Nathaniel Wayne and I am joined for
this particular outing by Ryan Daley
welcome to clinch about America and
about half of his voice well well more
than you deserve now that's fair so what
we're going to do on this one is we're
basically going to look at the movies
that I thought would be interesting to
talk about that are coming out in the
first quarter of 2017 so that's January
through March okay there's a couple of
movies coming out on the twentieth of
January there is split which is the
latest offering from M night Shyamalan
stars James McAvoy mm-hmm playing a
character with I believe its twenty
three personalities okay who kidnaps i
believe it's three young women and they
then are trying to figure out how to get
out and some of the personalities are
willing to help them some of the
personalities want to outright harm them
some of them seem indifferent some are
obstacles some are allies everything
about that sounds really cool and sounds
like really really interesting and i
could make for an amazing drum except
for the things that you lead with which
originally was the name at night
shyamalan like his track record to his
name is actually doing the opposite of
what main recognition should do at this
one well here's what i would say in
regards to split and it sounds like it
may it may have happened with the visit
as well which is that acne in the wake
of after earth okay it seems like no
one's willing to give them a budget
anymore mm-hmm and I think the
restraints of not having a hundred plus
million dollars to work with might be
forcing him to knuckle down and get
better i don't think i will see it
unless i hear glowing reviews i think
the i think that's probably a wait for
the reviews one for me as well now the
other one coming out that same weekend
is a vin diesel returning to the
franchise's we all want him to come back
to XXX the return of a vendor cage
because is there any more late 90s early
2000s ounded hero name than xander cage
so I never saw the other XXX movies me
that I was there two or three there were
two we always ever been ice cube came
back to be a long time never saw either
one I don't imagine this one breaking
that [ __ ] I I it's just so odd to me
that they discuss-- financed I mean at
this point it should be pretty clear
that that Vin Diesel actually white
shirt where is not a box office draw
himself the fast the furious movies well
I believe he is part of the appeal of
them people don't go to see him the fact
that only the first movie starring
Riddick made notable profits and then
the two that followed didn't really kind
of show me people aren't in this for him
so after that the last one I'll bring up
for the end of January resident evil the
final chapter on january 27 now this is
the six resident evil movie i stopped
after the third one I've seen bits and
pieces of my thing the fourth one I
don't even know that stuffed after the
arcade game in 1998 I've never see I've
never seen it this was another one where
I I haven't seen the person and it's not
it was never like a problem say I mean I
know I like milla jovovich things
although like we haven't seen any of
these I product that's probably happen
for filmography yeah it's just something
like the the franchise's just never
really appeals me I'm not a zombie fan
going to pass on this one this one holds
no real interest for me all I can say is
tangentially I have heard people who do
like this franchise and as far as like a
year ago they were hyped up and they
were excited for it well it's that at
most closest I can come to an
well that's not quite nothing I'm so on
februari third Raines which is the
sequel to the ring well I did it this
was supposed to come out at least almost
a year ago it got bounced from its
release date twice hmm I suppose would
be my questions is seems like this would
be a property that we're coming year or
two ago yeah this got bounced twice I
don't know what its original original
really stay was but it's being dumped in
at the beginning of februari okay and so
far as I can tell the only thing that
it's doing that it's trying to update is
basically bring the concept into the
internet and streaming age could so the
idea is now instead of having to pass
around a VHS people can just basically
forward a YouTube videos I won't see
this one figures maybe if it's some
night where I got nothing else to do
with it some if I can stream it or
something or is it so I'm gonna over the
channels book that it definitely talk
about test every other for a week so
it's a cast of unknowns it's a cheek at
which is part of why i'm slightly
surprised that they didn't ultimately
just dump it on DVD because they
obviously if there's any money in it it
went into the visual presentation of the
thing not on the caf even if you had
let's press me on what we were going to
feed illegal movies for good with like
one I wouldn't bother to do research for
this one of now I i won okay maybe we'll
get into something that well we'll get
into the febrile retent releases at
least one of which I'm sure you leave
care slightly about because the first
one of which John wick chapter two the
first one flew right under my radar
never heard of it i didn't know like I
asking if I some dimensions liked oh
yeah kind of reason to movie and as if I
would care about that but everybody is
suddenly everybody exploded over this
movie they were talking it often like
everybody was hiding it but it felt like
to me I was hearing all of that too late
to actually go out and see the first
now I do think it's gotten over heights
the action is phenom that's that's
repeat the action and is terrific it
loses a little bit of steam at the very
end I think the sort of the climactic
fight is doesn't quite measure up to a
lot of what we've gotten up to that
point or to lose a little steam at the
end but when that thing's on it's on and
here's the other thing that's really
cool that I think gives it that extra
edge beyond just being really cool
action okay it does a lot of really
fascinating world building okay it's a
very comic book world that it creates
actually in terms of the dynamic that
establishes of these hit these hit men
how they operate the rules they operate
under the reputations a lot of them pal
okay it's just really efficiently built
not realistic but awesome world i don't
think i will see the sequel unless i get
the chance to see the first one if i can
finagle within the next month or so to
see John wick it if it is suitably
impressed with me I might make the
effort to see John with two so the other
one coming out that same weekend the
lego batman movie there's a chance I'll
see it a decent chance to childhood I
like me some bat name and I was
impressed by the the lego movie I was
going to ask if you saw the like to see
the lego movie I saw it once it came to
like HBO or something really surprised
me and I thought it was charming as hell
really funny I thought Batman was good
in that in small doses so I was a little
bit hesitant okay you're giving him a
whole movie is this something that's
going to be able to sustain itself heavy
in the trailer self I have seen some of
them they look good but it's just Eddie
know where I'm coming from there the
recent sort of function in one of the
promo poppy there's like this this love
interest of romantic subplot between
Batman and Batgirl yeah yeah I was so
high on this movie and then you told me
that am I uh
and it looks like it actually looks like
it's not a thing where Barbara Gordon
might be older like she might actually
be she she is acting commissioner and
yeah and so she certainly should not a
teenager she's not functioning like
Batgirl whatever what let me know even
if that fixes the age thing that's it
ended Michael his best friend's daughter
that has always been my problem with a
batman batgirl raishin it's not the age
gap because they also partner that girl
with Robin and depending on the time she
might be 10 years his senior so no it's
the fact that Commissioner Gordon is
that means for a quote best friend and
somebody that he has claimed in the past
that is the only man I can trust you're
going to do that with his daughter and
not telling who you are or who she is I
hope that is not a major subplot of the
lego batman movie because i don't want
that to the track and i think it will
but probably I will see it in the
theater is I have a chance I'm still
planning to see it and I I might take my
daughter to that one because i can't
show her most Batman stuff unfortunately
she loves the batman animated series her
than she likes her some bad one I have
to be selective she could probably go
into this one okay not next I'm pretty
sure you have not heard of this but
allow me to describe this one to you on
the twenty-fourth of februari I'm moving
called get out this is a horror movie it
is and I've heard I heard somebody
describing this one okay oh is this some
is this Jordan tells me this is Jordan
Peele wrote directed what what the
trailer is painting as basically a risk
on the Stepford Wives the tackles racism
instead of imagining right right with
Bradley bit further away from the west
wing as like a closet prospective
father-in-law going with this secret oh
this no I'm going to predict this will
be incredible or horrible nothing in
between no it there's no sliding scale
for this one it's going to begin or semi
yeah this is cool and timely as hell I'm
going to be really curious because I
think they do little
doubt and I think unfortunately it may
have become even more relevant than even
a tiny made it right but there was no
doubt that this was coming from a place
of of anger and frustration right and it
can produce some amazing at times oh
yeah oh yeah I'm hoping to level that's
Josh's out of movie that I'll see the
figure I hope if it if it's arrived as I
get the chance I might actually seek
that level on march third Logan hmm I
didn't even realize it was coming up
that early yeah okay i will see that i
will definitely say I've seen all of the
x-men related movies I really I like
James mangal as a director copland is
one of my all-time favorite movies I
really liked the Wolverine really liked
it so about a half an hour before we had
this so i know it's somewhat based on
old man logan which i don't think i
don't think the actual story what it's
going to have anything i think the only
thing that they borrowed from old man
logan is how is putting it further in
the future and the look yeah he's an old
man in the southwest the r-rating does
that mean anything for you either way it
is not I've gotten a good Wolverine on
screen with a pg-13 rating I think you
look at from the second excellent movie
him going berserk in the mansion when
that I think that it that is a full-on
legit harsh will raising and the only
thing you can add to a theme like that
it's just a heck of a lot of blood right
here you're not actually going to get a
better or more visceral action sequence
you'll just get a mess feel I don't want
it to be rated R for the reasons that
Deadpool's right now I don't want it to
be rating them are because there's a lot
of swearing in a lot of blood and that's
not a knock on Deadpool that was a that
I've worked for that was a perfect fit
for Deadpool those are those are the
reasons they Deadpool movie should be
rated R if you're going to give me a
rain at our Wolverine I don't want the r
rating to be because of those reasons
okay i will be seeing this to bid
farewell to hugh jackman because I
yeah I believe this is just one smoke
ugly if you wants this to be I would not
rule out the possibility of him like
cami owing in Deadpool too but in terms
of full-on doing over and again i'm
pretty sure doc sure coming out of that
same weekend I'm assuming going for
shadow program t2 trainspotting okay um
this wasn't no I remember seeing the
trailer for this largo completely might
not be down public wait what ah I saw
trainspotting when I first came out I
liked it but I didn't like it as much as
everybody else I know like [ __ ] I
actually haven't seen it since high
school yeah I don't even know how to
hear that that it's one of the answers
wonder like 96 97 yeah yeah I know that
was a lot of time i saw i think i saw it
once most of the people i know what
crazy go nuts over they thought it was
like the best thing since sliced bread I
don't know okay I didn't really get it
that much I saw the trailer for the
sequel and this is this looks fun I'm
Carrie and what's interesting is I've
been hearing about this forever because
I remember probably 12 14 years ago
because the book seat because
trainspotting was a swappable or time
and the book sequel had come out and
someone had asked Danny Boyle would you
be interested in doing a sequel to drink
but now I'm not actually sure if the new
movie is based directly on that book or
not but I do know that Danny Boyle's
response was basically oh that'd be
great but they're all too young we gotta
wait like another 10 years and they need
to be legitimately aged away from what
they work we're ever going to do that in
so I kind of love the idea that that
basically they all sat on this until
they were old enough probably not a
theatrical viewing but I wouldn't be
opposed to seeing a vegetable alright so
next up on march 10.com Skull Island
okay I'll be interesting to see Tom
Hiddleston in a different kind of role
that world of movies i think i've seen
all of them I'm not living or dying with
this one I'm not only are dying either
but it did make my most anticipated
movies of the zeros because what I grew
up on the original King Kong so I think
I prob
more nostalgia wrapped up in the poverty
going to so when I say I'm a sucker for
it I am but I still need it to be good
sure though I'm have my fingers crossed
for this one because if it's good it
hits a soft spot okay cool so after that
we have okay this one I'm pretty sure
you haven't heard of but I i think is
interesting and worth talking about it's
called the Belko experiment comes out on
March seventeenth and what it is is it
is these people working at a company
called Belko one day the building disk
is locked down we're going completely
and instructions start coming over the
speaker and share it shows and the
directions like kill somebody right now
or we will kill 10 of you ok I have
heard of this I don't think I've seen
the trailer editing I've heard of this
now part of why I find this interesting
is it was the script is by James Gunn
okay and I have a feeling that if he was
not currently making guardian of the
galaxy this is the sort of thing he
probably be directing as well kind of
like that he's not he's not abandoning
all that because it in case folks only
know his work from from her guardians of
the galaxy he won he came up way back in
the day in Troma which is he did seated
screenwriting for Troma movies which are
you know intentionally low-budget
over-the-top schlocky huge gore movies
he wrote and directed horror movie
called sliver know which was sort of a
riff on the thing and from beyond it was
body horror is it funny certainly has me
intrigued um probably going to be
something where I wait and see or I wait
and listen to what people are saying
about it and how it is one of those
things where you know peek behind the
curtain we live in a rural area with a
small local theater so problem unless
unless we're willing to drive two hours
it's probably not coming around here for
its theatrical really good point your
point Hogan I keep forgetting this is
happening Power Rangers comes out on
march 24th really they've released
one domestic trailer three months ago
they released one international trailer
which was just a shortened version of
the domestic trailer they have shown
very very little of a movie that is
coming out in a couple of months and
what was in that trailer had like only
at the very end of that trailer did they
start to hit showing at the suits and
the outlets there was no hint of the
robots the swords there was no hint of
the monsters they would be fighting I
wonder if there really is like maybe a
half hour worth of general genuine power
rangers stuff going on here and they
don't want to admit to that because they
couldn't afford to do what fans will
have wanted them to do I started to get
a cannon films matches of the universe
vibe like I feel looking at that trailer
second time I'm like I'm starting to see
all the shortcuts you've taken to try
and save money I look at the fact that
like they're they're getting their
powers before they act there should get
the Susan like that could be cost-saving
it's the sugary of the suits involve a
lot of CGI or anything else like that
I'm just seeing all these things like
German really you're trying to stretch a
budget aren't you and do we care this is
not a property I particularly care much
about but I know there is all that's
important for how long it's been on the
air multiple generation the people who
do care about what and they deserve a
not crap movie yeah I don't want to say
I grew up with them but they were around
during my childhood and I remember
watching it I would probably a pass oh
my god it's a definite hat for me it's
just I feel bad because i don't i don't
know the grudge fandoms that I'm not
involved in turn in my mind if you like
something you deserve a good move a good
version of it sure I mean nobody should
have a crap movie for something that
they enjoy it anyway surely knows how
that feels yeah yeah so we both live
example with both lost five different
movies
yeah so last one will bring up ghost in
the shell fly and you've been public on
other episodes of everything and other
videos for how do you feel about us I
have never seen the original manga I
heard about long ago and I heard it was
beloved in late very good I've never
read the manga I've never seen the
original movies so I I know a little bit
about it's probably more by reputation
and sort of some of the iconic imagery
when I really cast ScarJo I was like
okay that seems like it's inviting
trouble where they could just hire two
Japanese actress at the other hand
ScarJo will bring in more audiences and
i really like Scarlett Johansson and I
like to look at her I'm not going to
really complain that I won't be that
local in my opposition to it so I saw
the trailer for it and I know you might
owe you have a lot of reservations above
it's just almost conceptually i'm
excited to us I think it looks really
really cool and again it doesn't I don't
have the built-in like established love
for this property I don't have all of
the the connection to it that you have
in all of your your prior knowledge I'm
just going based on the two or three
minutes of footage that scene and
something behind us what is behind the
scenes stuff acting a little really cool
I want to see this it's kind of nice for
me to hear from the perspective of
someone who doesn't know the property
and NZ and as of this recording I
haven't read the manga yet i'm going to
plug for my other podcasting venture
punch like a girl the plan is to have
the March episode of punch like a girl
cover ghost in the shell that's that's a
fingers cross because it's a book but
but so by the time the movie comes out I
will live read the manga but sort of my
love of the animated and my feelings on
animation in general sort of
unfortunately put it at a disadvantage
right out of the gate because just the
idea of and it's all the big screen in
live actually doesn't tell something
from make sure especially if I feel like
I've already won everything
done better in animation which I felt
actually about most of DC properties if
you want if you sell suiciding you want
a good Suicide Squad movie seek out
Batman assault on Arkham I couldn't get
you to see the jungle book because it
should be original now I still plan to
see this movie because ghosts michelle
has been made and readapted and
reinterpreted and there and at this
point because they're there are two
there's two films in the original
animated movies limited there are two
full seasons of a TV show there is a
series of there's a new word series that
they've done and they haven't just read
adapted the manga story every time so
there's tons of new stuff to pull from
what I don't want is for them just to do
what the original animated film did and
just do it in live action and that's
more legitimate yes but look if I'm
being fair if I remove my thing if all
they do is recreate that animation in
live action and you've never seen the
original animation it's going to be very
cool ok so I know that's one that i will
go I if if it comes to our small writing
I think that I'm against being out of
relief I will make the effort to see
that so yeah I think I think that'll
that will now wrap us up yeah so um this
might become a a quarterly segment and
maybe when we get towards the end of
March will take a look at april through
june call it a we'll call it an eye on
that one ride you have too much craft
what do you want to plug today ok I've
got a number of podcasts on the fire and
water podcast network that includes
Batman night cast midnight the
podcasting our power of fishnets and
give me those Star Wars I also the
writer of the webcomic called my pet
ninja which is available arising from
comics com and one of the co-creators
and writers of red and green a webcomic
also at Rising Sun comics com hmm okay
all right I don't he's done great okay
so thank you very much for joining me
Ryan and revenue if you are watching
this on youtube you can see a
edited on complete version of this
discussion on the council of geek
podcast available on iTunes and stitcher
in any case no matter how you are taking
this in thank you for joining and until
next time this council is a jerk click
that some button right here I'm button
right here click